let's bring in - Charles Davis you can
see Charles on NFL Network's live
coverage round two and three that'll be
coming up tonight starting at 7:00
Eastern let's start with the first pick
overall
all right with that one not a surprise
by any stretch of the imagination good
morning Dan good morning guys look they
went so far down the road once they
hired Kliff Kingsbury and when good
things Barry and the Cardinals brass
they got asked Kingsbury come in and
embrace Josh Rosen and attach him at the
hip right away methought about hey we
were considering this we were
considering that that's all just
smokescreen it was it was Murray all the
way and they would had called the
trigger last night had to happen
dangerous pick dangerous very much so
because you're going back to back you
were a quarterback brought in a guy last
year with a rookie head coach and he
woke that you're supposed to grow
together you decide Steve wolf doesn't
the guy keep the quarterback obviously
but Theresa and you're starting over
another quarterback the same guy made
those books the time so this what
doesn't work you and I'll be making the
next Cardinals I say this every draft
after every draft certainly the first
round I don't give out grades because
you're not going to know it made a
couple of years down the road for some
of these guys but I do look at strategy
the draft strategy with some of these
teams the draft strategy for what team
stood out the most either good or bad
for you well Green Bay for me getting
Rashawn Gary at 12 was a very good move
for them because defensive line depth
was a real problem last year by the time
the season get you know really got into
full swing Dan it was Kenny Clark and
they were trying to work people around
them because my daniels will serve Bob
and Wilkerson was hurt so that doesn't
surprise me at all especially when you
look at their board and they decided now
to go tight in there which I thought you
know with Robert onion coming back
expect could be better that didn't
surprise me okay because he had in the
Jimmy Graham and my ladies Lewis but
when they had the second pick and get
out that surprised me a little bit you
know I mean that downs down the stretch
so we'll see what goes on with them
because Aaron Rodgers talked about all
we want window winning championships
I thought they'd give him a little bit
more help because Darnell Savage
absolutely love them as a player thought
he would do in the second round but I
did hear a lot of conversation leading
up to the people liked him a lot more
and I think a terrific player but I
thought the Aaron Rodgers would get some
help in this first round
the Giants philosophy with what they did
and when they did it how would you rate
that it goes back to the old Dixon
theory if you have conviction about a
player we're going to in issues that
were not grading which I love all right
because it's down the road is when the
grades really come out how do they flat
but our first impression was if you're
going quarterback there who's the
highest rated quarterback on the board
at that time the public would have but I
think would have thought Dwayne Aston at
that point I think most people would
have said that Dwayne Haskins look at
South quarterback on my board
I had a second-round grade on Daniel
Jenna but that doesn't mean anything for
the Giant they think that he's their guy
and we talked about all the way up for
the draft and if you're going to get a
quarterback that you have conviction on
a guy you better take him in sick
because if you're trying to wait until
seventeen too many teams can make moves
to try and jump you and you do within
your own division Washington was likely
to go get a quarterback if at all
possible
so get your guy at thick in case your
guy was their guy and you just couldn't
wait and hope and that's what that's
what the Giants did so I feel bad for
Daniel Jones is welcome to New York
maybe like with no it's not exactly like
with Joe Namath gasps signed by the
judge that Broadway Joe and people were
excited people were excited about Mark
Sanchez number Sanchez when he came in
his reception will be a little bit
different but he has a great personality
in order to handle it and he doesn't
have to face the fire right away cuz Eli
will be the starter at least at the
beginning of the season who's the player
you loved in the first round last night
absolute love yeah well for for me it is
TJ Hawkinson from Detroit going there
and not shying away from the Erica
Bronco and taking the guy that really
like but it's interrupt about Hopkins it
is I like no offense but the down still
throw it a little bit better but
Hawkinson is your best combo Guyot I did
but was interesting to me is when we
drafted Wayne Haskins we all say the
same thing red shirt sophomore give him
time to develop quarterback right TJ
Hawkinson as a redshirt sophomore about
the same age if you ever hear any of us
say that did it ever come up no point
kid could join the Beach Boys and Gopal
at different positions we just don't
even do a JH the same black yeah just
tells me that a much bigger upside in
terms of what is out there and growth
maturity and he's a heck of a player so
I thought that that was a big concert if
ik time pick for them and I really think
Josh Jacobs going to Oakland at 24 was a
big deal and three picks in the first
round you can always wait and get a
runner but if you think back to John and
success rate and when they were really
cranking think about in Oakland and what
Charlie garner gave him think about what
they did in Tampa when they ran to the
Super Bowl and they got back for the
parade and John greedily leads the crowd
and a pound of rock camp he will run the
football but he also likes to be able to
throw it to his back out in the
backfield and Jacobs gives them a great
combo of that if you could have Drew
lock today in the second round or you
could trade for Josh Rosen with the
second round pick what would you do
let's say you're Miami I'm trade for
Josh Rosen because I don't have to give
up a ton of capital now I think that the
Cardinals lost great leverage throughout
this process
they keep talked about getting a one
corner that went out the window I never
said I'd always thought the bidding
started it - going into last night and
then if there was a bunch of bidders who
had expert pick that you could add to
the sweetener now people may be able to
get it free but get him for even less
but how about the contract forget it
you're getting all those extra fears
under the rookie deal
and his chump change based on your
salary cap Josh Rosen would be the guy
would go get he's already played 13
games and he didn't have a chip on his
shoulder before Dan he said that you
should have let us grow to Boulder size
proportion suppose if this is trying to
get back up the hill I mean each other
last year when he went 10th and went the
fourth quarter back I'm gonna prove
you're all wrong he ought to be doubling
down on that now can you look at this
and I know you know it's a year removed
and but you you have say Quon Barkley
Sam Darnell so they're gonna be attached
because the Giants decided to take the
running back instead of the quarterback
now I'm all I'm all in for that I said I
know what's a coin Barkley is going to
be and he turned out to be great I don't
know what Sam Donald's going to be now
he might turn out to be unbelievable
franchise quarterback but if I said you
can have sake on Berkeley or Daniel
Jones or you can have Sam darn old and
Quinton Williams what are you taking
oh boy well I'm where you are then
because I think you and I are very much
in the minority so let's get ourselves
in a corner and assume a fighting stance
we'll be ready to punch because because
most people would say you've got to get
the quarterback you know they've got to
roll off the last rushing leader Gannett
fell that won a Super Bowl was Terrell
Davis Denver Broncos so that's where the
games playing is played through the
quarterback position but I think
Berkeley is a generational player and he
played that way last year on a bad team
Daniel Jones was going to have to prove
that pick right hitch is what it comes
down for him I think both people would
take darn 'old and Quinn and Williams
because of the way the game is played
now I'm in the minority I thought the
Barclay pick was still an excellent pick
because they didn't have that conviction
of what quarterback they wanted
now Daniel Jones has to prove them right
and they pass work it's difficult
good stuff Charles great stuff last
night and have fun tonight
that's a Charles Davis NFL Network
analysts their coverage surrounds two
and three tonight at 7:00 Eastern for
more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience Channel
2:39 on Direct TV stream for free on VR
live or download the Dan Patrick show
app